[Music]
in august
of 2002
[Music]
a little less than a year after the
attacks on the world trade center
the american military was already in
afghanistan trying to weed out
the taliban and find osama bin laden
an a-10 pilot with the callsign johnny
bravo
was assigned to fly over a valley to
protect
22 special operations forces that were
making their way
through a valley to extract what the
government likes to call
a high value target johnny bravo and his
wingmen
flew the a-10 warthog which is a slow
low-flying attack aircraft designed
to provide ground cover for the troops
below
on this night the heavy cloud cover was
lit up by the moon it
made it look like the snow had just
fallen
johnny bravo was in contact with the
troops below and he got an uncomfortable
feeling from the tone of their voice
so he told his wingmen hang out up here
i'm gonna go down and have a look
he pointed his plane to the clouds his
plane
thrashed about in the turbulence as he
flew through the storm clouds
and when he finally popped out below the
clouds less than a thousand feet
above the ground the sight that he
witnessed he'd never seen
anywhere before not in training
not in combat not even in the movies
tons of tracer fire coming from the
sides of the valley
pointed right at where the american
troops were below
he didn't even know where to begin he
pointed his guns at
the source of some of the fire and laid
down suppression
good hits good hits he heard from the
troops below
he was flying at over 350 miles an hour
in a valley
that was only about a mile and a half
wide at its widest point
he'd count out loud to avoid hitting the
mountain one one thousand two one
thousand three one thousand
and at the right time he'd pull hard on
his stick pull a high g
turn go back up into the clouds to go
back
for another run his fuel was fine but he
ran
out of ammunition he flew back to the
top of the clouds and he said to his
wingmen
you need to get back down there and so
the two of them flew back
down into the valley flying
three feet apart from each other wing to
wing
johnny bravo counted while his wingman
laid down the suppression
one one thousand two one thousand three
one thousand
that night 22 americans went home alive
with zero casualties
i had the chance to meet johnny bravo
and i asked him a simple question
why did you do it those were unfliable
conditions
no one would have ordered you to do it
you've got a wife and kids
why did you do it and he gave me a
simple answer
because they would have done it for me
it's because of this unbelievable bond
of love and trust in the military
they give medals to people who are
willing to sacrifice themselves
so that others may gain in business
we give bonuses to people who are
willing to sacrifice others
so that we may gain we've got it
backwards
i want to work with people like johnny
bravo why don't we have more people like
him
in the private sector so i sat down with
johnny bravo
to understand how they build that love
this is a bit of optimism
jb thanks for doing this absolutely are
you kidding i've known you for 11 years
now wow
and i have to say of all the people i've
met in my life and you and i have become
good friends over the years
it is amazing how much i have learned
from you
and i've never told you this how much
i've learned from you
about service and integrity
and i'll tell you a story that i have
repeated to myself and repeat it to
others just one of the many stories
just about you going about your day but
the intense lesson
for me so i was supposed to come out and
visit you
a bunch of years ago and
i think was the day before you called
me and said can't come
he said we've had a bit of a an incident
on base
and i need to deal with it and if i
remember the details
a few junior officers went out drinking
with a junior enlisted colleague
they came back to base and
they were a little tipsy so they were
worried about getting pulled over by the
cops
and so they asked the junior enlisted to
take the wheel and she did
on base they got pulled over by the cops
she was breathalyzed
she was over the limit she was arrested
for drunk driving
and then it turned out that she was also
having a relationship with one of the
junior officers
and because of the way they acted they
either risked or were going to get
thrown out of
weapons school right and i called you
sort of after the fact it's like so what
happened you would just sort of
recounting the story to me and it was
what you said to them
that stuck with me because any one of us
who we have people who work with us that
they're getting in big trouble
we would say things like what were you
thinking how stupid can
you be you've destroyed your career
you know that's what we would say and
that's not what you said you said do you
know how many people you've let down
you've let down your parents who
believed in you you let down your
commanding officers who recommended you
for this program
you framed all of it in service terms
because when you serve
the reward is what you give to others
but when you screw up
it's how much you hurt others yeah i
cannot tell you how much that stuck with
me
oh that's amazing it truly is how you
feel i mean they're they're part of a
tribe a culture
and it wasn't hey what did you do to
yourself it's you have so many people
that believed in you and put an
investment
into developing that level of trust
and look what happened so i remember
that vividly it was a very unfortunate
event but more so
because of the bond that was broken
because of it what ended up happening to
them out of curiosity do you remember
one separated became i would say pretty
jaded
uh because of the incident and because
of the the trouble one state and service
is still serving
and really was like i'm going to earn
that trust back and is still serving
right now
good for him yeah and the junior
enlisted uh
she separated as well yeah what i love
about that story
so much is that you know i think that
our nation over the past many decades
has over indexed on this rugged
individualism thing
it's like the marlborough man really
isn't the hero
you know yeah and we've gotten away from
service and serving the tribe and
serving the community and serving the
nation it's all of those things
it's all become about our reward what do
we get right and
what i love about this is that service
it keeps you in check right
yeah because you think about who else
benefits from my work who else gets hurt
from my decisions yeah how did you learn
that did that come just because you
joined the air force and you learned it
from the air force or did that come from
your upgrading i would say a lot of it
came from the air force
a lot of it came from the a10 community
the a-10 is the aircraft you fly the
warthog
yeah the a-10 warthog and when we're
brought into that community
it is very ingrained into you early on
it's not about you like that's the most
common quote that we use
throughout when you are like man that
was a tough target to find or that was a
tough
problem to work to and try and support
the folks on the ground that you're
tasked to support
the feedback that you always get from an
instructor is hey it's not about you
it's about them so focus on how you best
support them
and to me that's where that really
starts to build in and what's
interesting to me is that's specific to
the platform and the aircraft that i
flew
but across the air force that's really
the mindset of every community
civil engineering is out there preparing
runways not for them but it's so
they can support the operations that are
going on security forces
are risking their lives defending the
base again not for them but
so you can take care of your airmen and
get the mission accomplished
and so that is brought into you very
early no matter what community you're in
in the air force
in different ways but we all have it in
our dna in some form or fashion
i've told this story publicly but nobody
knew that it was you
that when covid started and emotions
were all over the place
i called you and we had a very candid
discussion
about how to compartmentalize emotions
under stress
in your case what you learned about
compartmentalizing emotion in combat
and you gave me a very stern warning you
said we can't
maybe for a very short period of time
but everyone you told me
everyone suffers the trauma of combat
absolutely
yeah sometimes immediately and sometimes
many months later
yeah and covid is a trauma
and everyone will suffer the trauma of
covet at some point
yeah and i remember calling up all my
a-type personality friends who were all
trying to pivot their businesses and
pivot their careers and
everyone was in mission mode everyone
was mission focused
no one was dealing with anything and
some people
thought they had quote unquote beat it
in other words they weren't going to
suffer the trauma because they were so
good
to go and i remember calling all of them
and saying i got this warning
you know it's gonna happen at some point
my friend told me it happens to him four
or five months after he gets back from
combat
and i made this group of friends make a
deal that if we feel something
we call each other and i got calls
because of that counsel you gave me
a couple friends i'm thinking of one in
particular who called me and said i'm
struggling
and she didn't go to her husband because
he was struggling too and she didn't
want to burden him with it
yeah and she told him i'm calling simon
yeah and we talked every day
i think that's what i found amazing
about the entire
kovid 19 experience is it was as close
to a deployed
environment that i think you could
almost get in the united states when you
look at it
not similar from the standpoint of
combat but just similar veins of
conditions where
we're all under a shared experience
which is kind of like being deployed
you're like hey i'm over in the middle
of nowhere there's
very harsh restrictions or things that
we need to do much like we saw with
kovid there's a life
or death aspect to it there's a lot of
unknown associated with it
and it really kind of comes down to okay
how do i get through today how do i get
through the next day and that's when
i think you really believe and start to
understand like that
compartmentalization to be able to do
that
occurs you know like i talked with you
about you got to come out of that at
some point you will come out of that at
some point whether you want to or not
that's the lesson that i learned it was
tough for me coming back from my first
couple combat deployments
because i didn't understand what was
going on i was like man i'm kind of
disconnected
i'm dealing with a lot of stuff but i
don't know how i'm dealing with it i
didn't have the best habits or or
behaviors
and after you've gone through it a
couple of times then you kind of have
the epiphany of like oh i
i see what's happening like i understand
what's going on
and so in covid 19 you see something
very similar where it's like hey a lot
of people
are going to experience these same
things and my concern when we talked is
i don't know how many of them are ready
for it because in the military now
we're a little more oriented to know
that experience will happen
and to try and provide the support and
those kinds of things necessary
but for the public at large i hope
everybody understands that they're
probably going to have to go through the
same series of emotions
that we see in the military did you see
that folks in uniform
better able to cope with covert because
of the training that you received
yes and no i think what was most
interesting and
difficult was the military members
themselves
i believe had a framework because they
had been in that environment before
to deal and adapt but their families and
their spouses
did not and that was i think almost as
tough
was when you had a military member going
like hey i know how to deal with this
but i i'm having trouble supporting my
spouse who's going through this or my
kids who are going through this
is there anything that you learned
from your training that you wish the
general population either knew or knows
now
i think what i took away from my
training that the entire population
could possibly apply during covet 19.
recognizing
if you start to uncompartmentalize if
you will
and deal with that and you're either not
ready for it or you weren't prepared for
it
it doesn't happen on your timing like
it's very difficult to understand when
that's going to happen
and when you see those indicators
realize i need to talk to somebody and
talking to somebody
is about 80 of the battle just having
somebody that you can
connect with to share that experience
with
and for the receiver of that phone call
most of the time it's
just being empathetic enough to go okay
lay it on me i'm going to listen and i'm
just
going to understand it's not to provide
the fix it's not to provide the solution
it really is just to connect and what i
really take away and recommend is if
that hasn't happened yet
realize it is going to happen at some
point and try and get left of that and
just precede it
by forming those connections having the
discussion of what you've going through
it it will mitigate
a lot of the trauma that i think you may
experience prior to hitting it
it underscores so many things about the
importance of creating
really strong bonds of love and
friendship
deep meaningful relationships i've
talked to so many young kids who've
grown up in a very digital world and
they've said this to me that they
struggle to form deep meaningful
relationships
they have great fun with their friends
but they wouldn't call their friends
if they needed real help it's fine and
good
if times are good but it hurts me i feel
the pain because i know when
something inevitably does go haywire to
not have
a friend that you can pick up the phone
and say i need help yeah
you know that's what's interesting is
again when you look at the military in a
deployed environment or a lot of the
teams that we serve on the relationships
you form
are close to an absurd level like the
amount of detail
and dirty laundry you know about another
person when you are deployed you are
with them 24 7
for six months or a year or however long
that deployment is
and you really get to know the good the
bad and the ugly but at the end of the
day
you have that relationship formed and
the thing that may drive you crazy of
just i can't stand the fact that you
drink the last cup of coffee and you
won't make another pot
but i love you that's the reconciliation
that you have at the end of the day
when you look at the digital
relationships while there's a
relationship there that level of
intimacy i don't think
is inherent in it and there's also a lot
of nonverbal communication that you lose
due to the digital nature of the
communication that you again you see in
an in-person
relationship where your eyes on or
you're noting like hey your shoulders
are a little more slump today is
everything okay
but it's the good the bad and the ugly
that comes with that level of intimacy
that i think
allows you to be able to be vulnerable
and say i'm going through a lot of stuff
right now and
you know i don't want to dig into all of
it but just so you know i'm not doing
okay and then
for the other half of the relationship
to be like you know i'm here for you it
doesn't matter what time it doesn't
matter
where i'll be there and that's what you
get from a lot of those experiences and
i think
why for a lot of military members it's
so tough to transition
to the civilian sector because you lose
that framework that's built
into the culture every vet i've ever met
whether they love the military hated the
military
regretted leaving or couldn't wait to
get out every single one to a t
misses the brotherhood and the
sisterhood absolutely yeah
i mean we have colleagues and co-workers
you have brothers and sisters
and those relationships are real i mean
they are sibling relationships
yes absolutely i think the military is
so misunderstood with the culture of the
military's and i've had the honor of
getting to
spend time with you and get to know you
as a culture i've learned more about
what it means to be human from folks in
uniform
than i did from anyone who ever wore a
suit i've hugged more people in uniform
i've cried with more people in uniform
that's one thing
crying is totally fine you know it's
not a sign of weakness yes and
there's this love and intimacy that
exists as you said it's like
i love you for this the word love is
used a lot
oh yeah i wish the private sector
understood
they just think it's like from the
movies command and control and people
issuing orders
yes sir yes ma'am you know it's like
it's not like that at all it's a
household full of brothers and sisters
that love each other and hate each other
but will always be there for each other
yeah and i think the job is to get the
mission done and that mission is
something that's higher than yourself
because you talk about the defense of
the nation or
our priorities or our interests but at
the end of the day
i mean it really does come down to like
hey i'm gonna take care of you
or that unwritten contract of like i
don't know you at all but i'll take a
bullet for you
because i know you do exactly the same
thing for me and that contract is just
what we're brought up on
and that's why at the end of the day
you're like hey i've got my marching
orders and my mission and those kind of
things but
primary job number one is to take care
of you whether i'm responsible for you
or not that's really what it boils down
to
and if you think about the congressional
medal of honor the highest medal in the
land
sometimes the people who awarded that
medal disobeyed an order
or the mission failed it's almost always
because they were willing to sacrifice
themselves
to save others yes yeah is it because
the job is life and death
or do you think there's something there
that can be transferred to private
sector
well i think because the job is life and
death it does raise the stakes and it
does
make the importance of those contracts
that much more solidified
but i also believe we do have a
mechanism in place
where you are for lack of a better term
judged on
how you take care of your team how you
take care of your people
it's very tough to go tell somebody to
risk their life if they're like i don't
trust you i don't feel like you do try
and take care of me on a daily basis so
why am i going to go
try and accomplish this mission where i
may lose my life and so
within our culture i think there is a
lot
where the ability to take care of each
other the ability to have that level of
trust
the desire to say not only do i want to
take care of the basic functions but i
want to help you be a better person and
that's why i serve
at the end of the day those are all
things where we
value that and that's how we really look
at the job that it is that we're doing
and if you're not doing the job or your
values are not in line with that
we either provide feedback of like hey
you need to adjust or maybe it's time
for you not to be here anymore
how do you evaluate each other based on
how you take care of each other
some of it is i would say qualitative or
subjective
just when you look at an organization or
a team is it healthy is it vibrant
does it have good morale some of it is a
little more quantitative and putting in
360
degree feedbacks providing more
assessments surveys where you can have
that level
so it's a little bit of a balance of the
both it's very challenging it's a tough
thing
to have a good pulse on
is a leader taking care of their team is
it maybe more of a toxic environment
where they're looking out for themselves
and they're burning the team
but i would say that that is one of the
top concerns
of the organization overall is hey how
do we ensure leaders are developing
their personnel taking care of their
personnel
and not doing things from a standpoint
of
either just trying to propel themselves
or burning their team
at the expense of just saying hey i'll
get that mission done it doesn't matter
what i do to them
i would say there's a couple tools that
are in place to help you do that but a
lot of it is qualitative of just your
sense
as you look at a team you look at the
dynamics and go i've got a good leader
here who's taking care of their people
and
and making sure they're okay it's nice
to know that you haven't figured it all
out because we're struggling with it
in the civilian world i think the big
difference is the striving
which is it goes back to that planning
it's a wheel and constant motion
a striving to figure it out to improve
it to evaluate it
all the time too often i think in
private sector especially in in public
companies
which is prioritizing the shareholder or
the stock price
even if it burns the team is the
priority
and the mechanisms to evaluate the team
are secondary as long as we accomplish
this arbitrary goal yeah and i think for
us there's the primary objective of hey
we gotta
accomplish the mission whatever that is
but there's also an understanding of i
can't do that
if i don't have a good healthy vibrant
team
to be able to allow us to do that and i
think there is a basic responsibility
and understanding
when you are a commander in a leadership
position of i have a responsibility
to care for these members and and not
just from the standpoint of
hey here's your next assignment or
here's your next opportunity or maybe
here's an educational opportunity for
you
it's you it's your family it's your
spouse it's it's all those things
together
how can i give you back better than i
got you and to me
those are my responsibilities as a
commander and a leader right now is i
need to ensure my team is ready for
whatever it is they may face
and so if we were to go into combat and
they look at themselves in the mirror
and go i'm not ready for this that's a
failure on my part that's primary job
number one they have to be ready for
that
right hand in hand with that is i need
to take care of you as a person i need
to know that you're being developed
you're improving your leadership
skills and tool set you've developed and
your family is well taken care of and
i'm managing that talent because
that is a responsibility as a leader is
to really
care for the team that i have i want to
underscore that because that i think is
such a profound statement
which is to give them back better than
when you got them
for an employer to say whether you stay
in our company for a year or ten years
that you will leave our company a better
version of yourself than when you joined
us
because of your time with us is an
incredibly powerful standard and i think
is the standard that helps
any leader understand what their
fundamental responsibility is which is
how do i make you a better version of
yourself
and give you back in better shape than i
found you yeah and i i truly believe
that i tell my team
one of the lessons that i've learned is
it doesn't matter what your endeavor is
you'll always better serve that endeavor
with
leadership in an attitude of service and
again it's not about me
than without that and so it doesn't
matter what you're
going to go do in life you may
transition to the civilian sector you
may decide
you want to be a stay-at-home parent you
may decide i want to be ceo someday you
may want to just decide that you're
going to be chief of staff of the air
force someday
having those leadership skills and
having a sense
of this is bigger than myself and how do
i give back
is going to serve you throughout so how
do i help develop those qualities
and provide you what you can use to go
forth and conquer those things
and and again i look at that as my
responsibility as a leader
and then on the commander side it's the
responsibility to go and hey as a team
we're all going to try and accomplish
this mission together
what have you learned in the military
that you've been able to translate as a
parent
because you've got three kids i would
say a lot of lessons learned
primarily from the standpoint of that
empathetic leadership
because my kids have had to move around
they've had to
deal with kobe just like i've seen other
families deal with kovid
and i do the same in the flying
community where i've been through
experiences and i'll try and tell a
young pilot like hey listen this is
where
either i messed up or something that i
learned i want to hand that to you
so you can be better than i am and i
feel the same way with my kids i'm
constantly trying to provide the hey
listen i didn't do this so great so
take it from me go in this direction but
still having
and allowing the freedom for them to
skim their knee here and there
so that way they can learn from it as
well and and really trying to establish
that relationship of
i'm here to provide again the kind of
the framework of our culture as a family
but also
i'm an instructor i'm i'm here to give
you the lessons that i have and
the hopes that you're better than me
someday and you can make an impact and
you can go
this is such a good lesson there are so
many leaders out there
who try and teach those on their team
what they did right so that you can
learn to do it right also
and i think we do that with kids right
which is i'm going to tell you how i did
it right so you can learn how to do it
right also
and what you're saying here is you're
telling those on your team you're
telling your kids
let me tell you when i did it wrong
which i think is a nuance but profound
difference as the lesson learner i mean
even for me when
because i have such respect and
admiration for you
that when you tell me the times you
screw up
what it does is it makes me feel i can
do this
i can work to that standard because
he gets it wrong but if all you did was
tell me all the stuff you got right i'd
be like i'm out
i can't this is unrealistic
[Laughter]
i think that's the two aspects of it one
you know as you know i
graduated from the weapons school and
for those that don't know it's like the
air force's version of top gun only
better
but our our mantra there is humble
approachable and
incredible and i believe the humility
part of it means a great deal it's to
say hey i'm not perfect and i i have
messed things up but i want you to learn
from that
and i really believe that with my kids
and it also establishes a level of
vulnerability where it's like hey
you can see the real me you know there's
not a facade here i'm not putting up
this wall saying i'm 10 feet tall and
perfect
i'm scarred up and i have no problem
hugging those scars and saying
you know this is what i've learned and
where i am today and i want you to
benefit from that
and it's worth saying because i know
this there's a little detail that i know
in
living that humble approachable
incredible mantra
that you would never say what actually
happened which is you graduated number
one
yeah well i was very lucky yeah
you're easy to embarrass yes yeah
because all i have to do is point out
the stuff that you actually excelled at
and it drives you nuts
it does absolutely i have a question for
you
i think one of the scariest moments for
people in the military is when they make
that transition to the civilian sector
and like we talked about
will they find something like they had
in the military that level of trust
that those friendships those bonds that
camaraderie of brothers and sisters
is that out there with what you've seen
from corporate america or within
companies
is that magic ingredient anywhere to be
found
i often tell people like i think we're
going to have to create it
you know when you make that transition
take it with you and create it wherever
you are
there are precious few companies that
have it
and one of the major differences is that
you know companies very often say we're
like a family
but they're not yeah because you can't
ask family members to leave the
organization you don't ask
right and in the military because you
sign contracts and because you're there
the family bond can be actually made
more real
because you can't hire and fire people
willy-nilly like you do in private
sector
yeah and so private sector is more like
a team
sometimes players get cut yeah it's much
more like a team than a family
that said there are some of those teams
that care about their teammates
that see their priority as building a
great team and winning comes second
versus what too many coaches think which
is winning is the priority in
team be damned yeah and so there are
precious few companies that do
have that same deep love and respect and
camaraderie that you have
but i think you're right i think folks
who transition
they need to bring everything they've
learned and build it
yeah and i think one of the things i've
seen over and over is
regardless of how big their egos were in
uniform and regardless of what rank they
wore
there's this inherent insecurity that
they bring to the private
sector that i don't know your world
i don't have anything to offer i used to
fly
this plane or work this electronic
system that doesn't even exist in the
private sector
and so there's quote unquote what am i
going to do and there's
so much that folks in uniform
know whether they were in command or not
there's
so much that they know about how to
build
friends how to build brotherhood and
sisterhood how to create
love what the value of devotion to the
person to the left and person to the
right
is to accomplishing the mission it's not
god and country
it's the people to the left of me and
the people to the right of me that i
risk my life
yeah and though you won't have to risk
your life there may be some jobs that
you may take that you will but
but for the most part you're not going
to risk your life anymore
but you still have this incredible skill
set and they don't talk about it
in an interview when they say so what
can you bring to us you know after you
know
10 years in the military what do you
need done
what do you need and b i know how to be
a team member
and build a team that is willing to
sacrifice their life for each other
and you don't even need that standard
and i do think that private sector
benefits
hugely when they have veterans on their
teams
if the veterans recognize the strength
that they bring and
do not have an inferiority complex when
they join that's good feedback
it's not told enough to folks who are
transitioning the strengths
that they bring to private sector that
just do not exist
those skill sets just desperately
lacking in fact the reason i have a
career
is because i'm trying to teach the
private sector i'm trying to share ideas
with the private sector
that i'm learning from the military
every book i've ever written right
has at least one if not multiple
military stories
yeah that's incredible it's just like
the private sector has such a
misunderstanding of you
guys i think you guys have such a
misunderstanding of the private sector
they don't give you enough credit and
you give them too much credit
yeah yeah that's valid
and that's based on my living with one
foot in each
yes it's challenging you know it's again
i was thinking about it flying in the
red flag mission i flew in yesterday and
we come back to debrief and we're in
this mass auditorium they show up the
whole mission and it's just filled with
everything like
there's a level of discipline that
you're providing feedback on i'm like
hey you didn't
make this time to the second there's a
lot of snarky
and sarcastic comments flying around and
poking fun at each other
there's a lot of dejection when you find
you didn't quite win and the level of
teamwork and camaraderie is just amazing
and i know
from the standpoint of what i think
military members want when they
transition is they're looking for
something like that they're you know
they're searching for it and don't know
where to find it
it makes it very scary the good news is
i think
the world is moving in that direction
yeah yeah absolutely it's going to get
better
yeah i love you brother i really do i
love you too i
love talking with you and for me to be
able to give a glimpse to the world
who you are and and how you actually
live your lives
i was able to get through my trauma of
kovid
because four or five months in right on
schedule
i was off my game badly and i didn't
want to use the d word because i felt
like it was a clinical diagnosis but i
was depressed
and because of the counsel you gave me
that this was gonna come
i was prepared and the first thing i did
was call
and ask for help and one of the people i
called was you and uh
you saved me you know i i'm very
grateful to you
well you know i'm always always here for
you always yes
the feeling's mutual brother i love you
i love you too brother
[Music]
if you enjoyed this podcast and you'd
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself take
care of each other